ucciso qualcosa ciao ragazzi per tornati
al nuovo standard di caduta il tema
della puntata di oggi è come rimorchia
la gente però punto così importante ho
pensato di invitare all'interno degli
studios è casa mia la persona che è un
attentato un pochino stella polare di
questo programma ma che allo stesso
tempo è l'unico che è finito di una
puntata a un certo punto è scomparsa
diciamo che questa persona era notte
permesso di conoscere ma che caltagirone
quindi ne sono doppiamente grado sia te
questa l'opportunità che mi hai fatto di
essersi prestato a tornare all'interno
degli studios di casa mia sto parlando
di martina affido ecco perché non
rispetta profondamente toccata perché
sono un po pronto in tanti ma ho fatto
beach volley ma che stai a di cosa fai
nella vita e nello sport per terra
spalmata un tappetino magari da questa
passione bravata un panettone buffon dio
ma ce la facciamo tutta così grande così
questa volta mi ha lasciata per fargli
capire cosa fa martin ad appena arriva
ciao o ds farne
non sarà cadetti può suonare che penso
io ma ci fosse una il pianoforte
semplicemente del pianoforte ma mattina
tu arrivi ha intenzione uccidere che poi
partire solamente come non è il membro
chiave del portiere dice 17 m che quando
messi inventare caso imi sir efficace lo
si sente propinarci tranquilla perché le
società fanno centrica ebbene quando
dicono che no che la minaccia molti ma
il che lascia a tutti
[Risate]
ospite un ragazzo ha cercato di
macchiarmi è bella e il bello di prima
coltello siciliano così abbiamo già
iniziato una diatriba che all'interno di
questa casa è presente una persona anche
in questo momento non potete vedere che
è un fotografo e si chiama giudici su
quel nome nato sostiene che si legata
arancina mai detto io so che questa cosa
scalera inverno sotto i commenti che il
tema del bio scomparirà io ho bisogno di
capire dice mancino in cima ha però anna
siciliani sapete quante galaga ma lerda
romana io saprete lancino assomiglia a
una lancia certo perché l'arancio i
grigi parata parola cambia a parte la
sicilia un'altra parola che il ciclo e
non posso dire normato e in un'altra
nazione
comunque la cosa positiva è che se ne
son pochi ma se avete le mani comunque
cinque regioni e quindi lasci in
qualunque volta assomigliamo nino
d'angelo eravamo dire dante lo trovo con
confini ma è un modo per dirne uscire
bellissima pazzo video nino d'angelo
adesso vediamo assomiglia nino d'angelo
vagamente agli occhi chiari come nino
d'angelo numeri ma forse era ubriaco
un bellissimo messaggio da ricevere
americano jack black hawk è passato dai
peggiori comunque quando ci siamo
conosciuti vettore il sichuan dove e
ashton kutcher chelsea 0
lui è figo cosa certo perché ti piace la
erre moscia lì non lo sapevo la tecnica
di marcia e 11 nel caso di un ragazzo
stanco ma è un caso quando lei
all'inizio su ambiamo lager verso di noi
italiani a seconda che si è più brava
cosa ti dicono azione questo è tipico
dalla conta per questo qui disponiamo
sbagliato gol subito è stata proprio la
chimica di meno che sono un cantato
l'hanno chiamato come supermercato
minimacchina già in remoto brava io un
rimorchio cioè sede che per metà sono
gli occhi malissa via magari era curiosa
bellissima strada da pagare
ho guardato negli occhi con te e poi
abbassato lo sguardo del perdere i soldi
di fare il mio di morchio decisamente
questa simpatica carina
esatto penso almeno lascio un graffio
così ricordato come molti misteri quindi
che le persone ci provino
se ti piacciono ospite ciao corticelli
negozi per chiedere delle informazioni
insomma delle scarpe il commesso mi
guardava insistentemente i bellissimi
io però non ho mai a vita nel senso ma
le ragazze siccome anche se ne rendono
così tanto conto punto dico perché e ti
stanno così l'access ha detto capelli
invece pecche come ce l'ha generato un
volo rossi quanto viene qualcosa da bere
così rifarsi con il tuo aiuto
me lo ha chiesto studiolo c'era scritto
ai degli occhi km di kaki bellissimi
sono uscita dalla sai che credo di
essermi pentito d'aver ti invita quindi
tutti quanti amori fiocchi
beh certo non elette
i nostri occhi ma chi e come se costa il
medico è fatto apposta
e lì con girone con noi ma anche a me è
successo volta ma sono stati bravissimi
in treno ne torno a casa ea un certo
punto aprendo mi ricordo sarà una gelida
un vero se ne è caduto quasi da film che
tutti ci si rovina si sono mantenuti
marzo perché poi dico ti scrivo cioè
anche solo dell'interazione
automaticamente ad un canale certa
finisci per prendere in giro comunque
per dare del fascista round va bene
anche stile grazie a spinetta lo
studiano e certamente un ragazzo
divertente di passo il suo telefono che
dentro c'era scritto ciao risposto
niente poteva parlare ha capito fra
segreti risponde a un giochetto che si
era creato tu subito tragica club.la
subito la persona peggiore di mosca per
il semplice fatto che dio non approccio
per sono orgogliosissima e tende a non
fare mai il primo posto amen che si
trova alla ragazza che gli piace di la
sbatte in faccia
in tutti i sensi andiamo avanti
aggiungere a questa colorita di una
prescrizione ormai da mesi e poi
ovviamente il flagello peggio della
passione di cristo
mamma mia
dal molo di una donna non sei antiquato
però non è uno che sembra che prudente
cioè se tu sei dark non sei tutto nero
con adesso non più per essere quello ma
perché riferita la mia faccia
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo video in grado di narrare molto
più bello non è tutto bellissimo spiega
come fare una tv di stato
la gente però vabbè scrive come si fa
addirittura che in cui my head and the
ragazza da dividere in quattro
questa ragazza davanti dividono in
quattro
dividete di quattro quindi così in
quadranti guardo in alto a destra o in
alto senza un altro in alto esterno al
orribili del in quattro e ficcate grazie
ovviamente anche adesso direttore di
morire aveva mondo dei vostri messaggi
aver contribuito a questa rubrica ma
allo stesso tempo per aver comprato odio
questo video fino a qui
iscrivetevi a questo canale aki la tela
campanelli cartello di chi le prossime
uscite ma soprattutto il prossimo
giovedì con la vita affrontare
in pratica una canzone manager che
schepp che si è molto brava tutte ma
perché è italiano e storia
[Musica]
renzi